how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and of course
mcu and with only a couple of days left
until one division
episode 8 which is going to be the
longest episode that we've gotten so far
and of course the finale coming up in a
week and a couple of days
things are getting super intense
especially with all of the reveals that
came in
episode 7 and if you have not seen
episode 7 or anything leading up to it
here is your official spoiler alert
episode 7 revealed agatha harkness
not like we didn't really know it was
her because we did but the way they
revealed her
was pretty epic her taking the twin boys
and wanda discovering her evil lair
then showing her that she is actually
the one that's been behind everything
all along but as we're going through
agatha's lair and they're showing
different things
inside of it there is a very important
scene not only for one division but the
future of the marvel cinematic universe
as a whole
so let's break it all down but if you're
new be sure to subscribe and hit the
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest one division videos
so as i just mentioned marvel just
changed the entire mcu in one division
episode 7 by introducing
the darkhold the darkhold is the book
that we briefly saw in agatha's lair and
it had magic kind of flowing out of it
and it means a lot more than you think
it does
i believe this book was actually stolen
from doctor strange and we'll get into
that in this video but i believe agatha
is about to bring one of the biggest mcu
villains
a god villain into the mcu's earth
dimension with
this book and i'm not talking about
mephisto or nightmare not the normal
villains i've been talking about for one
division
i'm talking about an evil god villain
now this villain and agatha needed wanda
and her sons or at least
one of her sons to return this is why
everything is happening in the story of
one division to bring this big bad to
earth
and eventually doctor strange and wanda
are going to have to fight not only
agatha but to fight this god villain as
well
now to understand who this god is we'll
have to go into the history of the
darkhold because he created it
this evil god villain is chathan you may
have heard me mention him before
and he has such a huge connection to
wanda in the comics
now to start it all off chathan actually
created
the darkhold eons ago chathan wrote
every single thing that he knew
all of his spells his hexes everything
onto a piece of indestructible parchment
which was made out of flesh
eventually it was transcribed to stone
and the pages were bound together
creating
the darkhold also known as the book of
sins or the shiatra book of the damned
now some of you may know and be familiar
with this book because it actually made
an appearance in agents of shield
however
don't get your hopes up i don't think
this will be connected at all to the
storyline of agents of shield
i'm pretty sure the president of marvel
studios kevin feige doesn't count
agents of shield as canon to what is
going on in the mcu so don't get your
hopes up there
but this book is insanely powerful it
has all of the knowledge of an evil god
and this god had a very specific purpose
for this book
and for the scarlet witch now in a story
in the comics chathan is actually how
wanda gets her powers
chithon was actually on the earth
dimension for some time until he gets
banished
and even though he's banished he still
tries to get back to earth
and at one point in time chithon
actually reaches out to
an infant girl and marks her as a
possible vessel for him to use one day
to get back to earth and of course that
girl was wanda maximoff
and his apparent marking or blessing is
what gives wanda her chaos magic
chatham would go on to possess wanda
multiple times throughout the comics in
order to try and get back to earth
but he also had another way before
fleeing to the flickering dimension as
it's called in the comics he left
another way for him to get back home
on earth and that was the darkhold
chathan used this book not only to
infect
earth with his influence and his spells
but also in hopes to use it as a
potential gateway
between the dimension he was stuck in
and the earth dimension to return one
day
now we obviously know that the mcu
doesn't really copy the stories from the
comics they kind of take a baseline from
the comics and then create their own
story around it
so in this case i don't think wanda is
marked by chathan
instead i think either both or one of
her twin boys are
it's fairly obvious at this point in
time that wanda's twins billy and tommy
aren't really vision's kids they're
wandest kids but they're also somebody
else's kids since she was
impregnated by magic i believe that
chithon
impregnating her could be his mark and
just like as i've mentioned with
mephisto and nightmare before the same
applies for chathan this could be his
way to finally get back into the earth
dimension by impregnating wanda with a
part of him
his marking a part of him is in the
earth dimension
and this could be the start of him
returning however he would need the help
of something else
the help of the darkhold and a servant
to summon him and the servant of course
is agatha harkness
now how did she get the darkhold where
did it come from
well although we have not seen it yet
but probably will get a scene where we
see it it looks like she
stole it from doctor strange's sanctum
in the first doctor strange film
where steven is learning the mystic arts
he continues to progress until
eventually he needs to progress
even further it's there where he starts
to go into the forbidden books
and in one scene we can see that where
the books are being held they're
forbidden books
there is a book missing now some people
are saying that this is the book that
cacelias took but casilius only took
pages to a book and the book still
remains at the sanctum
so this book right here is most likely
the darkhold the one that agatha
harkness now possesses
now agatha is a witch of over 10 000
years old so she is going to be
extremely powerful so she could be
capable of breaking into the sanctum and
stealing this book
and the masters of the mystic arts and
the sorcerer supreme would definitely be
responsible for protecting
this book this book is how chitton could
return
an outer dimensional god being it's like
the sorcerer's main job to make sure
that beings like this
don't return so they were definitely
looking after it but it looks like
agatha stole it
and this is actually going to be the
connection of how doctor strange is
going to show up in one division
although it's not 100 confirmed it is
widely expected that doctor strange will
eventually show up in the finale
and of course kevin feige the president
of marvel studios has already confirmed
that one division leads
right up to doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness it takes place
right after one division and this is
another reason why the dark cold being
taken from the sanctum makes perfect
sense
protecting earth's reality as doctor
strange says in avengers infinity war to
tony stark
is his job now what exactly is agatha
going to do with the book
with wanda and the twins well yesterday
my co-host christ of my channel cosmic
culture
posted his own theory of what the book
could be used for and if you haven't
checked my other channel out be sure to
head over and subscribe i'll link it
down below but this theory
involves the nexus commercial that we
got in episode 7
and what we believe is that this book is
going to be used in some way shape or
form to manipulate the multiverse
a nexus is a connection or linking
between
two or more things like two or more
universes or dimensions connecting to
each other and here's what i believe is
happening
chathan needs a way to get back to earth
in the comics chathan marked wanda as a
possible way for him to get back to
earth
but in the mcu in one division he used
his magic to impregnate wanda
marking both or one of the twins and
this
is the nexus this is the connection
between him
and the earth dimension since he's the
father of the twins a part of him now
lives in the earth dimension
and now all it takes is a very very
powerful spell
a spell that he wrote himself and put in
the darkhold to bring him back
and this is what it's all been about
chatham needed a magical being
somebody strong enough to use as his
vessel to return
so agatha put a hex on wanda created a
perfect world for her where she would
want kids
it's been about kids the whole entire
time it's been a huge theme
for the children right in episode 2 it
was right there in our face
for the children and now agatha has the
children and her intentions are to use
the dark hole to summon
or bring back to the earth dimension
chathan and i believe that she will be
successful
i kind of think that it will only take
one twin to do this
so perhaps one of the twins will survive
but i do believe that chathan is going
to be summoned and i believe that that's
how doctor strange gets involved and he
will be
the main villain of doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness
but let me know what you think about
this theory in the comments down below
and don't forget to subscribe with the
notification bell turned on so you don't
miss out on any
of the latest one division and mcu
videos don't forget to like the video
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof
you